James Gunn and Peter Safran's plans for a
brand-new DC film and television universe
include self-proclaimed superhero from
the future Booster Gold. With rumors that
Chris Pratt could take on the role, fans are
already imagining what that might look like.
The hierarchy of power in the
DC Universe has indeed changed,
but in a very unexpected way. After taking
12 weeks or so to suss out the direction
of a multibillion-dollar franchise
with nearly a century of backstory,
new DC Studios heads Gunn and Safran
have unveiled the start of their shared
onscreen universe. And they've confirmed that
Booster Gold is coming. Yes, that Booster Gold.
"He's a fascinating guy. He's a
loser from the future who uses
future technology to come back to present day."
With the announcement of a live-action
small-screen adaptation of the just-shy-of-A-list
hero comes a necessary tsunami of speculation.
At the front of the queue is Chris Pratt,
who Gunn turned into an international
movie star with 2014's "Guardians of the
Galaxy." Gunn has already been respectfully
honest about his intention to slap a "dibs"
sticker on the backs of performers that
he's previously worked with in the MCU,
and that has some fans wondering: Wouldn't it
be crazy if Pratt played a futuristic, immature,
wisecracking, perpetually down-on-his-luck
comic book character? You know, again?
"Listen, I'd love to believe
all of this. I really would."
So would a lot of fans! But let's be clear:
There's no announcement that Pratt has been
cast as of the making of this video. Still, that
hasn't stopped all kinds of online speculation.
Reddit user clutchkweku has ensured that anyone
eager to see what Chris Pratt might look like as
Booster Gold didn't have long to wait with
a post on the Fancast subreddit. In fact,
the poster seems to have already known something
the rest of us didn't, much like Booster Gold.
On December 18, 2022, the fan artist
posted their concept of what Pratt might
look like as DC's fifth or sixth favorite time
traveler. Utilizing the AI program Midjourney,
this surreal marriage of the famed
raptor wrangler and weirdly shiny,
unreal superhero clothes somehow
simultaneously calms and unsettles,
as if the light on an anglerfish's head was
made out of the star of "The Tomorrow War."
Reactions to the computer-assisted artwork
ran the gamut. One commenter who said,
"I do hate that this works particularly well."
Another called for a casting swap. saying,
"Chris Pratt should be Aquaman."
Meanwhile, outside of this particular comments
section, the idea of Pratt making the leap to the
DC Universe has become quite the debate. Some fans
love the idea, while others, of course, hate it.
Booster Gold first appeared in DC Comics in
1986 in the first issue of his self-titled
solo series. The premise was perfect for the
year after "Back to the Future" came out:
What if a schlub from the future traveled back
to the past, using the advanced technology of
tomorrow to find celebrity and fortune today?
The answer was a fan-favorite mostly-hero with
a smarmy streak, who shuffles back and forth
between overconfidence and impostor syndrome.
Since his introduction, he's appeared
in two live-action incarnations,
first played by "Days of Our Lives"
actor Eric Martsolf in an episode of
the final season of "Smallville." Donald
Faison later played him in what turned
out to be the series finale of the
Arrowverse's "Legends of Tomorrow."
For a better introduction than his live-action
incarnations, check out the "Justice League
Unlimited" episode "The Greatest Story Never
Told," where Booster is voiced by Tom Everett
Scott, and his robot sidekick Skeets is portrayed
by Billy West, who was Fry on "Futurama."
"'They also serve who only
stand and wait.' John Milton."
"Oh yeah? I got one for you.
'This stinks.' Booster Gold."
While Chris Pratt playing Booster Gold
is still fan speculation at this point,
it's clear that if he is cast, Bradley
Cooper will have to voice Skeets, right?